Is desiccated liver recommended?
So desiccated liver, if I didn't recommend it for you,
and I know you don't, I didn't recommend it for you,
but is desiccated liver a good thing
for people to take?
Sure, it's great, as long as you have a good source.
And almost all any good, good supplement company
is using a New Zealand liver source
where it's much less adulterated food sources
for the animals and you've got a good, clean liver source.
So yes, desiccated liver can help stimulate liver function.
Desiccated organ can help stimulate that organ issue.
And we're, you know, I wrote an article
on using desiccated organ supplementation
specifically for autoimmune diseases
because there's a philosophy out there that,
you know, since you have antibodies to self tissue,
let's say it was thyroid, like Hashimoto's,
like the example I just said,
and then you take desiccated thyroid,
it can help that immune reaction
that you would have against your thyroid
actually take place against that desiccated tissue
that you're consuming, it calms your thyroid itself down.
So you're gonna be very helpful.
But desiccated organ tissue has also been very helpful
to help replenish the basically hidden,
unbuilt nutrients of that organ to help rejuvenate that organ
so it can be very beneficial.